[Music]
all right let's get into it man so glad
to have you have you back and I just
wanted to before we even begin thank you
for all the wisdom that you shared last
time you were on the show to date it is
definitely one of the most impactful if
not the most impactful podcasts that
I've done it's been listened to by
hundreds of thousands of people not a
day goes by where I don't get a message
about it or a tweet even today somebody
tweeted about it so it's exciting to
have you back to go a little bit deeper
well it's a thrill I think yeah it takes
two to tango and it's your wisdom that
kind of pulls this out of your your
audience and your visitors so I
appreciate all that you bring to this
mission of public education really that
you bring this podcast so well
it's the least that I can do but you're
you're in the trenches doing the real
work I'm just the cypher here without
you for those that are that are new you
know we're gonna we're gonna dive deep
but I don't want to entirely recap what
we talked about last time everyone
should definitely go back and listen to
our first episode which I'll link up in
the show notes but essentially your work
kind of boils down to making the case
for this profound link between
environmental degradation and
degenerative illness essentially and the
distinction between the science of
disease and the science of Health and
looking at all of this from a 10,000
foot view in a very holistic sense from
the soil all the way to cellular biology
it's not fair enough
it is yeah and it's a really a story of
simplification in some ways and so I the
education that we love to give our
children and as well as our doctors as
everything is complicated and yes the
more complicated you make it then the
more opportunities for subspecialization
in knowledge and you know over the last
decade my whole team scientists
clinicians you know now farmers
everybody else who's in on the mission
we're finding out that biology in the
end is the same thing over and over
at fractal levels you know but you can't
have human health on a planet that
floats in the middle of a vacuum space
that's so vast and not to have to come
to terms with the fact that that human
biology is just a small niche within
this massive ecosystem of life yeah it's
it's a conundrum because as human
culture and society progresses and
evolves
it's almost natural law that we become
more and more specialized and
specialization has its advantages it
allows a single individual or a small
team to go very deep on a particular
issue and we learn a lot about things
that way
that is the scientific method but what
we sacrifice is that grander perspective
the inter relation between all of these
systems and the interplay and how that
all kind of works together in this
symphony that either is moving us
towards health or away from health
perfectly said and I think that lays out
I mean in some ways that is the mission
statement of the next you know three
four decades in the last podcast
together we outlined the science and
data that we have mathematical models
that we have around human survival and
at our current pace we've got one in
three males in the United States now
sterile one in four women infertile and
so you we're losing the ability to
procreate as a species and on our
current trajectory we've got about
seventy years left of human life on
earth and if you try to make the
argument well only the unhealthy people
are are dying so maybe it's the poorly
educated maybe it's those with poor
access to food and we can look across
the sector's right now and say well it's
just the deep south that's really
tipping off or maybe it's the Native
Americans or the Native Hawaiians or the
Eskimos it's these native populations
that are really suffering the worst well
that was the case kind of an initial
decade but now we see double PhD
families with very high associated
income with a kid with autism and two
other kids with debilitating asthma
allergies and anaphylaxis and learning
and delays and everything else and so
it's now crossed in all sectors of
socioeconomics
and it comes down to the fact that you
might think that you can outsmart this
thing maybe you've kind of found this
niche socioeconomic niche or an
educational niche that you feel like
well I'm gonna be isolate like I
understand human health is collapse and
you understand you know social
structures in the clouds but there's
gonna be an enclave of humans that are
gonna survive the Erewhon crowd yes
exactly
and so there's that I think there's a
huge contingent that are in that hope
and we can see what our billionaires are
doing right and so our billionaires were
making that bet and you got an Elon Musk
and you've got you know bees oh so
they're buying a plan for space travel
you know they're building space stations
to leave Earth and go repeat somewhere
else you know and so if that's the game
plan if that's the inner feel is like
you know injecting himself with young
people's blood and all kinds of stuff
crazy rides going on in the hubris of
this or the shortsightedness of this
perhaps is that it's not about if human
health was was an isolated event that it
would make sense to put young human
blood inside of an older person that
would that should make you very youthful
but of course it we've seen very little
evidence of that actually sustains life
the fact is that our biology keeps
proving in the labs is it's the
microbiome
it's these invisible ports parts of the
biology on earth that actually are the
inherent physiologic building blocks of
human health mm-hmm the the
chronological age of a human being is
not its biologic age and so you might
say I just got stem cells from a 15 year
old well unfortunately a 15 year old
today as a biology of a 60 year old in
the nineteen fifties aren't really true
you can see this degradation in all
kinds of elements within the biology
most of all and in the rate of healing
and so we walk around with a very simple
ratio a simple ratio of rate of injury
and rate of repair and that's that's
everything that's aging process
that's chronic disease that's any
process an acute injury if your healing
rate is at the same pace as that acute
injury you might be sore for a couple
hours and then you're gonna be better if
you start to see that rate of injury
outstrip the rate of repair then you see
degradation using rapid aging in the
1960s the entire US population of all
ages have carried chronic disease
diagnosis in four percent of the
population today 2015 numbers we don't
have anything more recent than to rely
on yet but 2015 we see 46 percent of our
children with chronic disease yeah I saw
that statistic it's it's shocking I mean
you you paint a very dystopian you know
almost sci-fi movie you know view on the
prognosis of the human race just to kind
of go back to what we glossed over very
casually a couple moments ago these
infertility rates are insane like that's
really true that what is it one out of
twenty four one two three males and one
in four women are having fertility
issues that's something that you don't
hear a lot about you would think that
might be front and center of something
like the Centers for Disease Control or
the National Institutes of Health that
might come and sort of added statistics
for sure yeah I mean these are yeah
these are large studies that are
screening problems like and these are
not even new statistics like polycystic
ovarian syndrome which is the leading
cause of infertility in women right now
in the US and other parts of the world
it's actually chemical toxicity and
other things coming into play and I
think chemical toxicity is kind of at
the root of PCOS as well but solid
polycystic ovarian syndrome even back
around 2008 2010 we were seeing one in
four girls in America and so it's these
are not even new numbers they're not
even numbers that would be a statistic
that's row up on a headline anymore
because the data's old and so the
numbers may be more dismal than we see
for the large part because even our
numbers that we see one in four girls
with PCOS well those are studies looking
at girls that are you know captured
through some sort of Public Health
Program which of course we have a
horrible track record in this country of
doing Universal screening I think if you
universally screen all the girls in an
inner-city environment
now you would find even higher rates of
infertility in that Wow and so we have a
really stark reality today but on the
flip side of that dystopian possibility
is the opposite view that if we change
our relationship to nature such that we
go into a co-creative process with
Mother Nature and we can do this through
regenerative agriculture of the
foundation so if we go into a
regenerative agriculture concept not
just in our soil science but in our
human biology I think we could very
rapidly in the next 200 years
see the entire Earth you know being a
verdant Garden of Eden where humans have
figured out how to co-create within
nature that our technological advances
and and continued specialization perhaps
and all these things lead to co-creative
processes that that augment nature or
work within nature's processes
so just topia meets extreme optimism
yeah and I think that's that's the
struggle right and in some ways we're in
a battle right now for for morale yeah
we have a lot of people with brilliant
solutions at hand but they're fighting
against a common paradigm that is
keeping the rate of progress at a crawl
yeah I call it an arms race it really is
and there's a ticking clock here it's an
interesting it's another conundrum it's
like this mashup of brilliant minds who
are making giant leaps forward in terms
of longevity science you know
extraterrestrial exploration like you
name it we're we're in the midst of this
extraordinary period in history where
we're seeing breakthroughs at a
breakneck pace at the sea
excuse me at the same time there are
such strong powerful well-funded forces
working day and night to enforce a
status quo that is rapidly leading to
the denigration of our environment our
planet human health all for the sake of
short-term monetary goals for lack of a
better word or quarterly earnings
reports yeah and who's gonna win right
and
I think if we have a chance at
prevailing it's gonna require a
grassroots movement of people really
waking up and taking an active role in
not only educating themselves about what
actually is going on but getting
involved in making that change possible
represent agree and one thing that I
continue to be encouraged and uplifted
by is watching as as you and many others
help my message and science get out
there wider it's putting me in contact
with circles of people that are more and
more not only accepting but really in
tensioning the discovery of what are the
solutions that we need at hand and so
I'm increasingly encouraged that at all
elements like last two weeks ago I was
in Telluride and and speaking to five
classes of high school students and
these kids not only got the message they
were in they left feeling like there was
a new sense of purpose at the high
school level of what they need to do in
the next thirty years to contribute to
the survival of humanity yeah you were
at that what was the ideas fast for
something like original thinkers yeah I
had a couple friends and podcast guests
that were participating in that and my
friend Colin was like a tea master and a
Chinese traditional Chinese medicine
doctor came back and he's like manner
this guy's act was she was gonna blow
your mind I go yeah that guy's coming
back to the body so yeah it's getting
out there which is cool and I want to
work our way towards towards the
solution that you that you kind of
introduced there but let's let's immerse
ourselves a little bit more deeply in in
the weeds of what's actually going on i
mean you you mentioned the fertility the
declining fertility rates i looked at a
couple other alarming statistics one out
of every two men and one out of every
three women will suffer some form of
cancer diagnosis during their lifetimes
not including skin cancer the autism
rates have doubled in the last six years
now it's one out of every 36 kids is
correct that's great of course
depression anxiety these things are
ubiquitous 46 percent as you mentioned
of kids have a chronic health issue and
there's projections that by 2030 one out
of every three children will be
diagnosed somewhere on the autism
spectrum it's insane
and that's not even getting into heart
disease diabetes obesity a common ones
right yeah yeah it's not even getting
into those and so you know we can debate
the biology and the chronic disease is
all day long but even if we were off by
a hundred percent on those numbers like
what if we were a logarithm off on those
numbers the fact is is even today if we
if we froze progress where we are today
with the rates of chronic disease we
have in the the financial burden that's
putting on our country we're in an
insoluble state already
I think our national military and
defense budget which includes things
like homeland security and bunch of
other stuff in there it's some around
seven hundred billion dollars a year and
that's a lot of money to spend on being
isolationist and maybe being a bully
around the world but it pales and given
comparison to the three and a half
trillion dollars that were spent is
spending on chronic disease management
so we are you know sometimes you know
somewhere in the ballpark of four to
four to five times more on chronic
disease than we are on defense and I've
spoken to one of the authors of Carter's
2000 reports so Jimmy Carter in late 70s
commissioned a whole team of brilliant
economists agricultural experts
education experts the technological
experts everything else and they were
supposed to write this for 2000 report
that would tell us in 1978 what's going
to be happening in the year 2000 what do
we need to be ready for to be
competitive as a nation on the national
stage so brilliant forward-looking thing
I think is really one of the few
presents that had the foresight to look
far beyond where his presidency could
have ever been relevant to that story
and in that commissioning when I talked
to the author of it you know he's he's
now in his you know mid to late 70s and
he said you know that
the biggest shock to everybody who wrote
that paper was how they nailed
everything they really didn't miss in
1978 they they predicted the
technological boom the they even had
iterations of the internet predicted
they had all kinds of profound foresight
onto what was happening and he said the
only thing they completely missed was
the chronic disease explosion mmm nobody
could have possibly predicted that at
that time that humans could have gone
from four percent to forty six percent
of our children with chronic disease you
know or four percent entire population
to forty six percent of our chronic
disease our children and so that that is
why we're economically failing is the
great minds that have been looking
forward 30 to 50 years for saw a lot of
what we wouldn't need financially to
stay soluble but nobody saw this
doubling and doubling and doubling of
the the the health care budget and you
know all of the reshuffling of the deck
chairs that we've seen with Obama's
administration well of course going back
to the Clinton administration their
effort at health care reform Obama
finally pulling that together after Bush
kind of disassembled the Clinton effort
and now we see Trump this is some this
is something Obama's effort the fact is
not a single element at no moment in
their did we create a soluble plan for
the health care industry and so all
we're doing is reeling deck chairs on
how are we going to continue to sustain
this rate of growth of expense it costs
us six to eight percent more every year
to take care of the chronic disease in
this country and so you can fast for a
decade and you can see that rate of
doubling coming quick and so at this
rate we'll be spending somewhere around
five trillion dollars a year on health
care by 2025 you know so with our next
president is going to face that kind of
crisis at the financial level and now
you start to picture what would it look
like if one and three children were
autistic in 2035 just if that was the
only disease that existed it would
us financially it takes um two
to three people to provide for one
disabled individual over the course of
their life and so you're taking out you
know this huge you know two of those
children left to take care of their peer
for the lifetime of that appear
meanwhile being coupled with the largest
geriatric population in history that has
a cancer rate of 70% and so that is a
grim picture is it's beyond fathoming of
what we would have to do financially
right now and and laying on top of that
just our basic systemic structure for
dealing with this isn't healthcare it's
sick care it's basically managing
disease and diagnosing and prescribing
without much thought or or intention
being placed into what's causing these
illnesses and preventing them before
they arise yeah yeah and if we tackle it
from the Western medical standpoint
which is we need to figure out the
biology of cancer we need to figure out
the biology of autism we need to figure
out the biology of all these different
seemingly disparate disease processes
because they affect different parts of
our body that's been the you know the
billion-dollar pursuit of all the
pharmaceutical industries and all of our
universities for 50 years now if we had
to wait for that tall untangle well I'll
be dead long dead before that all
happens there's no way that our species
will survive that slow pace of
processing because what we're looking at
as scientists are human cells that are
highly damaged in a petri dish that is
sterile completely isolated away from an
ecosystem by that very definition of how
we do science we don't understand what
human life looks like in the context of
an ecosystem and so we're so flawed at
the basic level of exploration that we
will never find the solutions and so
we've known since 2005 with the first
genetic kind of untangling of the genome
of the microbiome so looking at all the
genes of all the different species of
bacteria fungi parasites everything else
that lives in your gut we got snapshots
of that very clearly by 2005 by 2010 it
was very clear that every cancer that
happens in human body can be correlated
with missing some portion of that
microbiome you know here we are you know
almost I'm pushing on 15 years later
and nobody in the cancer realm is
talking about replacing your microbiome
to get rid of your cancer they are
attacking chemo surgery radiation exact
same story that exists in 1968 and so we
have not progressed the clinical science
because we don't have a way to take this
basic information of ecosystem data
there's an ecosystem a micro flora
there's this isolated human being
because our mechanisms of studying are
in this isolated space of the petri dish
we can we can't put those two pieces of
data together right in anything coherent
story and so that's where our lab has
tried to jump out of that petri dish
space and start working instead with the
farmers to start looking at the lineage
of health and watching soil regenerate
is very encouraging and I think it tells
us something about the human journey
that we have we can lay out ahead which
is where we built a nonprofit called
farmers footprint now and all of our
money from our biotech companies and
everything else is pouring into you know
supporting this bigger mission of the
farmers and so we're now on the ground
with farmers all up and down the Midwest
from Minnesota down to the Mississippi
Delta where we've dumped the vast
majority of the roundup and glyphosate
and done them the most decimation on
earth and he soil on the planet and
working with them on the ground we've
seen that you know every year that
they've done chemical farming their crop
yields fit and drop and I think we
covered that a little bit in last
podcast but that dropping yield was
something I had read about and by the
time this you know this past February
were shooting this documentary up there
we got to see it in real real time in
June July middle of the burden your
growing season you try to throw a shovel
in chemical farming soil and it's like
concrete
there's no is your it's a solid brick
that you're trying to push the shovel
into you have no aeration you have no
earthly application as an amazing
statistic it came from one of our
farmers who's doing farm training for
farmers stop spraying roundup a single
application around up in a field will
kill 50 percent of the earthworm
population
50 percent down with one spray they
spray multiple times in the year over
and over over and over and you
fast-forward 20 years you got no
earthworm's left which means you have no
air down under the soil which means
you've lost the architecture and the
aerobic environment you need for them
the micro rise a which is it looks
almost like coral reef mycorrhizae are
these beautiful hair like fibrils that
grow up through the soil and they
provide just like the coral reef the
home for the bacteria the fungal
elements isola and scaffolding or the
architecture upon which they adhere it's
the ultra structure of life right down
there in the soil and and that's gone
and then it's in a chemical form so we
went into this mission to say everybody
needs to eat organic well it was
devastating by end of our trip in
February we find out that the organic
farms throughout the vast majority of
the US are using tilling which is what
all the chemical farms do - they till
their ground so you drive by these if
you've ever flown or dried and driven
over the Midwest and wintertime it's
just fields and fields of fields of
black soil mm-hmm there's nothing
growing and it's not covered it's
totally exposed
that's a tilled field when we till we we
use a mechanical process rather than a
chemical process disrupt all the
earthworms kill all the earthworms kill
the micro eyes they all that through
killing it turns out that when you
switch from chemical farming over to an
organic process one of the things that
tends to happen you start to over tell
you start to tell more because you want
to spray the weeds you try to tell the
weed into the ground so - what is the
intention behind tilling what is the
what is that trying to accomplish it's
interesting when you ask the farmers you
know because my mindset was it must be
to get rid of the weeds but it's
actually an aesthetic the farmers
actually just think it looks better and
so the landowners that the farmers are
often leasing from want to see a well
taken care of farm and in their mind
massive landowner and and it's
interesting that our farmers no longer
own their land right and so we've taken
that land away from the family farms
they're no now owned by a hundred
thousand acre million acre plots by some
massive conglomerate or or maybe some
wealthy person who doesn't have a clue
really about farming perhaps
and often leads to some form of an legal
indentured servitude its indentured
servitude and we can go into detail and
the amount of death that the
relationship between the bank's the
landowners and the and the farmers is
extraordinarily insidious it's just it's
got everything frozen and petrified in
the in ancient processes because they
can't move forward financially but if we
just take a look at that that simple
belief that a plowed field or a tilled
field looks clean if that's what the
farmer says I can't not tell my land in
the fall because then my landowners
gonna think I'm a bad farmer and so it's
this just simple and you're like
seriously like you know you're doing
damage to the to the soil but but you do
it anyways and then some of them say
it's also a great form of relaxation and
meditation for me to be out in the field
because there's looks kind of messy and
I can just drive along for hours a day
and I can look back and I said just did
all that I just clean that whole
thousand acre swath over the last week
and it looks spotless now and so there's
the they literally do it for
entertainment they do it for our sense
of accomplishment they don't do it
because it's good for the soil they
don't do it because they think they
should to grow more crops they know it
doesn't increase their crop yield and so
when we go in to educate these farmers
need support on every level they need
support to say a farm shouldn't look
like what our modern farms look like you
have freedom to go make a farm look like
whatever it needs to look like to grow
healthy soil but to do that like we said
you got to get the banks involved and
these these farmers are you know the the
farmers that we're featuring in our
first docu-series with farmers footprint
are to still own their family farm and
so these are 350 to 400 350 to a
thousand acre farms that have been in
their family for at least four or five
generations but are these on the like
the sort of Joel Salatin model no just
traditional times EMI farmers now I got
you and so they drank the kool-aid in
the 1990s that they were gonna be able
to grow more soybean and corn so these
were already big big time commodity
growing farms by the 1980s you know and
interestingly it's been generations
sometimes since these guys grew gardens
you know they've
large monoculture commodities for one or
two or three generations and so and you
know the first form we are featuring
we're one of the first adopters of the
Roundup Ready GMO crop in 1996 and
farmers measure their entire not only
success as a farm but their self-worth
by how many bushels of soybeans they get
out of their soybean plants up that year
and they'll all tell you they all lie
you know and that's it's just this funny
culture just like fishermen they all get
together and somehow the fish got four
inches long yeah it's this story of like
well it was really 29 bushels an acre
but 35 sounds reasonable so I'll throw
that in at the bar I got 35 bushels an
acre and so they all kind of Josh each
other behind the scenes like yeah and we
always fudge each other because nobody
wants to tell the real story which is
their dads were growing 40 to 45 bushels
an acre and at 40 and 45 bushels an acre
they they were making ends meet in 1992
1993 1996 rolls around
Monsanto rolls in and says we're gonna
be able to increase your crop field by
six seven eight percent great that
sounds amazing
because dad's not making much money and
it's hard for me to think about staying
on the farm as the next generation so
we'll do that so they jump in and even
within the first year soybean yields
went down not up and so they went back
to Monsanto comes to sell them seed the
next year and say it didn't work like in
Monsanto every year it turns out and I
didn't know this as a consumer but every
year or every two years they would
continue to come back and say we've
region ethically modified this this has
got a new you know twist on it that's
gonna increase yield in the seed in the
seed and so it was this this constant
reiteration of the same story that never
came to fruition there corn yields never
went up and that's not what we're told
as consumers we're told that we need GMO
because it increases how we're gonna
feed the plant is gonna have this is how
we are feeding the plant everything
yields across the world and we're you
know we are we are responsible for the
ability for farmers to produce on a
level that they would not be able to
without us
corn yields never went up swiping went
down consistently and so this farm after
15 years of GMO farming had dropped to
below 30 bushels an acre there at 26
bushels an acre so pushing half of their
yield that dad used to get with with
normal conventional seed that had no
genetic modification process in it
meanwhile in that 15 year period the
banks had drank the same kool-aid that
that conventional seed was dangerous
because it didn't yield as much and the
banks know that the farmer can't pay
back their their loans that they have to
take out every year to buy the
commodities on the front end and so the
so they think that the farmers going to
go out of business if they use a low
yield seed which we've bitten they've
been told just like the farmer is going
to be a conventional seed so the loans
become contingent upon chemical farming
yeah and so now the banks think you have
to chemically farm if you're going to
survive and not but you have farmer
students telling you telling the bank
that look my yields are dropping every
year
apparently there's a few community banks
that are starting to realize just
watching the data come in that this
isn't working but they're having a hard
time getting out from under because
actually most of those small banks are
actually you know within the the arm of
some large bank that needs to be
convinced otherwise as well and so the
bureaucracy is cranking along again
super slow to see any need for change
meanwhile the farmers are losing their
farms and you really you and I not being
not carrying on our father's tradition
of income can't really I think
psychologically understand the pressure
these guys know yeah I mean I am I am
part of that you know erawan generation
you know I'm somebody who's so
disconnected from what that life must be
like I can I can attempt to sympathize
but I can hardly empathize with how
difficult that must be to even just
survive under what is essentially the
stranglehold of this gigantic almost
monopolistic corporate entity known
formerly as Monsanto and
now is bear that is pulling the strings
and controlling every aspect of food
from seed all the way to the
pharmaceuticals to treat the diseases
that it produces and I think it would be
good too we explored this at length last
time but if somebody's tuning in for the
first time there they will be inspired
to go back and listen to our first
conversation but I think it would be
good to just briefly contextualize this
this whole debate and argument around
Monsanto and and glyphosate by briefly
tracking the history of how this came to
be to produce the situation that we now
find ourselves in yeah so Monsanto was a
chemical company that was developing
chemical warfare for throughout the
1950s and 60s and so they were very
involved in the development of chemicals
like Agent Orange and these things that
we were using to defoliate the jungles
of Vietnam so that we could see the the
Viet Cong better and exposed the Ho Chi
Minh Trail and do our bombings more
accurately and so they were part of this
mission to you know kill life before
they got into the farming in history and
so there's a long track record there for
that company wanting to kill biology and
they you know Vietnam was wrapping up in
the early 70s they were losing market
share there quickly and so they were
looking for more mundane ways to make
money and they found this patent for
what would become glyphosate and roundup
as old patent is from like 59 1959
written created by a Japanese scientist
who kept it on a shelf wisely and and
didn't think there was a safe human
application for it I think and so that
that can patent got purchased and they
were trying to use it actually to D
clogged sewer lines initially it's a
potent key later it pulls mineral out of
whatever it touches which is probably
not what you want to do to soil right
but nonetheless they were putting this
in pipes to chelate and try to clear
clogged pipes from mineral deposit
trying to work quite well for unclog
the pipes but when it came out the other
end of the pipe it was killing all the
life in the pond and around the the
ponds and everything else and so then
that gave them the idea of it looks like
a pretty potent herbicide and so they
put it back into play as a weed killer
and so that then quickly marched in
1980s we see that get approved for
direct-to-consumer sales and so you
remember the big Super Bowl commercials
with guys the backpacks have roundup
with the pistol grip sprayers and they
walked out and they spray five
dandelions in their driveway and then
they walk back in with dramatic
soundtrack and so that direct consumer
message put a gallon of Roundup in every
single garage in suburban America what
wasn't mentioned in those commercials as
its water soluble toxin and it just got
sprayed onto your driveway which is
washing right down into your gutter
which goes right to your municipal water
system and so by the by the end of the
80s we're drinking roundup from I think
the majority from homeowners not even
farmers and so we start drinking this
chemical not having any clue that it's
there or any clue that it would be
dangerous because the tagline for
Monsanto was safer than water mm-hmm
well at this point
Monsanto actually published in late 80s
the the cancer-causing effects of this
compound glyphosate roundup and they
were studying in mice and they were
showing major birth defects and cancers
and sarcomas weird things and so this is
their own data and they published that
and that's still in the public domain
you can go find Monsanto's original
things if you can't find it then
Stephanie sunette from MIT has done a
great job of kind of putting a library
together of those those original
Monsanto documents and so they knew it
was toxis but I think the reason they
were comfortable in that out is the
threshold at which they thought that was
going to be harmful they didn't think
they'd ever reach because in 1988 and 87
when they were publishing that stuff I
don't think they could have believed
that they would be able to genetically
modify a crop by 1996 that would handle
that and so it was just being used as a
spot sprayer the amount and water
everything else was quite Trace because
at that time before they'd manipulated
the seed population if they used too
much it would just kill the part you lay
on the right
corn-soybean kills any plant you spray
it on right and says a non-selective
herbicide really you know and so I think
that you know they couldn't have even
foreseen their own success in some ways
in the late 80s and so they were
publishing that data saying that it
might be toxic at these higher levels
but when would we ever be able to use
that medicine that glyphosate in the
world by 1992 was when we started
spraying it directly on crops and so it
started being sold as a desiccant or a
drying agent to the wheat weed is the
only staple crop that you want dead
before you can harvest him and so they
were spraying wheat in northern climates
initially and now it's kind of gone
worldwide and every single year since
1992 we've sprayed more acres of wheat
with glyphosate and it dries it quick
and it allows you if you have bad
weather coming you can kill it quickly
and harvest it three days later so that
you can get your wheat harvested before
it rains or before the water comes so
there's a lot of you know economic
incentive to the farmer to desiccate the
wheat at times not a lot not all wheat
farmers use it but enough American
acreage got covered in this that we
started to eat glyphosate and gluten in
the same bite and so that's really the
development of gluten sensitivity
started right around 92 and with each
acre extra that we sprayed with Roundup
we saw the increase in not only
including sensitivity but the autoimmune
disease celiac disease so what is the
interplay between glyphosate and and
gluten sensitivity yeah so my my PhD
that works in my lab and at the
University of Virginia is a brilliant
brilliant geneticist dr. John Gill day
he has done an extensive work in areas
of hypertension and cancer and all kinds
of things but he really has been the the
smartest mind that we have behind
understanding the role of glyphosate in
the human biology and his science has
been incredibly landmark in that he's
recognizing that the glyphosate injury
of the gut lining which is induces a
hypoxic injury as soon as you exposed
the gut lining to to the glyphosate
chemical you get this lack of oxygen
injury to the gut lining and one of the
results of that
to be the overexpression of CXC r3 which
is a receptor to the gluten compound
gliadin
and so now you grab that with that
gluten breakdown product and it induces
the production of something called zon
Yulin Sanyal Innokin ZUP the tight
Junction via this unzippering of the
whole gut lining and now you have leaky
gut and so it's this sensitization of
the gut lining to glyphosate that
creates the receptor that would even
grab the gluten compound to cause a
problem and so that's is really why
we've been able to have gluten in our
diet for thousands of years without any
measurable you know immune impact and
then suddenly in the 1990s we have a
huge swath maybe 15 20 % by then now
we're looking at maybe 60 70 % of the
American population with some form of
gluten sensitivity and so just an
amazing you know that's amazing and
that's is that also why you hear
anecdotally like how I go to Italy and I
have pizza or I have pasta and I feel
fine yeah you know terrible crisps on on
the streets of France you feel fine no
problem come back to the states you have
one piece of bread and you've got brain
fog for three days that that is the
reality is that you know Europe's done a
good job of reducing the amount of
roundup sprayed in their current in
their countries unfortunately they did
get infiltrated by the GMO world but you
know France has vowed that they're gonna
be you know GMO free within the next
couple years Russia has made actually
the strongest stance on that that
they're gonna be GMO free and a fully
organic nation but I think they said
2025 or something like that so it's
bananas that's Russia having that
mindset that you know we this is the
most important thing we could do for
national security as Russia would be to
create an organic thing and I feel the
same way for the United States as an
American I feel like my highest duty
that I have is to help this nation get
to health security again if we don't it
doesn't matter what we do with the
military what we do with our our stance
on you know our international political
relationships or anything else it just
doesn't matter we can't contend on an
international level in 10 or 15 years
because we're broke
we're already the deepest in detonation
that exists and and yet you know we
continue to leverage leverage leverage
largely because we have so much debt on
the health care
yeah it's it's devastating but there's
been some interesting developments since
we last spoke kind of fast-forwarding
through this Monsanto timeline to
current of course we have the big
landmark Monsanto trial that resulted in
a two hundred and what was it eighty
nine million dollar verdict for that
groundskeeper who had non-hodgkins
lymphoma who prevailed at trial and that
spurred I think at the time there were
maybe eight hundred or a thousand
lawsuits pending now there's something
like eight thousand mm-hmm right so what
is there's a there's a couple things I
want to talk about but like what is the
import of that decision how is this
going to play out what's it gonna look
like when the rest of these these cases
go before juries first of all I don't I
mean huge huge interesting landmark
cases you say it was the first case out
of the many thousands that have been
brought before that one that was allowed
to go to jury and the thing that was you
know really allowed to go to jury was
not just the science of why this guy got
non-hodgkins lymphoma which is the most
common cancer associated with glyphosate
the lymphomas and leukemias are the
easiest ones to track back to the
glyphosate injury but the the judge was
the first to allow data to go forward
that Monsanto had known that this was a
cancer-causing agent since the 80s and
that that data could be put into the
core place for the first time and he
didn't the burden of proof wasn't that
he had to prove beyond beyond you know
he didn't have to definitively prove
that his non-hodgkins resulted directly
from glyphosate it was had had to be a
contributing factor I think was how they
adjudicated it yeah and it's very
difficult even if that is a clearer
pathway than other cancers how do you
specifically I mean that's a very heavy
burden to shoulder to say well this is
what you don't I mean if you're smoking
to say I got lung cancer from cigarettes
even you can't definitively
prove that right and so exactly they
prevail yeah we still haven't had a
class-action lawsuit on cigarettes and
lung cancer right and so you're exactly
right and you know it's optimistic as I
tend to try to be I I'm not sure that
that's that verdicts gonna be allowed to
stand I mean there and keep appealing
until they can until the cows come home
I think in the reality but the the
realist in my brain has to step back for
a second and say why now why suddenly
after thousands of efforts did this case
be allowed to go to trial why suddenly
did Monsanto be want you know let this
thing get to the point where they're
paying out 200 million dollars to an
individual what could possibly be the
rationale for that and if we back up for
maybe a less optimistic standpoint we
can say the major event that happened
within weeks or months ahead of that
trial going forward was the sale of
Monsanto to a foreign entity and so bear
the largest pharmaceutical company in
the world arguably but certainly in
Germany purchased Monsanto for 67
million dollar there were something
billion dollars right and so that's
sixty seven billion dollars moves you
know the the court environment I think
to a different district right and so I
think whatever you know impending stuff
we have right now is yeah I don't know
if anybody outside of the the deal
makers for the Monsanto Bears they've
seen it but I've a feeling there's if we
took a look at all that paperwork we
could see that there's gonna be you know
a time period in which case these court
cases will be allowed to move forward
and then suddenly bear is gonna be
completely untouchable and within days
of the completion of the the merger or
the purchase of Monsanto they dissolved
the legal entity of Monsanto right
they've retired that time the name they
dissolved the entity they just made it
disappear and so now we have all these
cases against Monsanto that is now not
lost and it's a standing issue now yeah
right and so I think it answered one of
my biggest questions right before all of
that on
my biggest question was why is Monsanto
selling itself for sixty seven billion
dollars they provide seed to 85 to 90
percent of our commodities the United
States their worth has to be far greater
than the sixty billion dollars and so
how could they be selling themselves for
pennies on the dollar to a foreign
entity what would be the impetus behind
that number one maybe they saw the
writing on the wall said this is not
looking good there's too much data
public sentiment is stacking up against
us higher and higher every year we need
to just cut and run get out from
underneath this situation but it's also
possible that there's a bigger situation
at play which is again the international
commodities market and the Monsanto you
know by 2002 we had hit 85 percent of
our corn and 95% of our soy bean grown
by GMO if that wasn't if it wasn't that
hit those numbers of a 2002 so in 2006
we had hit those and so we've seen this
huge domination of the single seed
source for us calm eyes but now if you
look in the developing world it's India
you've got China
you've got Australia buried in it New
Zealand Brazil's one of the largest
importers of it and say you've got
swathes of the entire or 7 billion
people in the world that are consuming
some sort of GMO crop from this single
source so sixty six billion dollars
sounds like a lot of money to you and I
but it's a pittance compared to that
global commodities environment in the
years right before the move for Bayer to
go purchase Monsanto they got approval
from EU regulators as well as the US EPA
and USDA to go in with a new genetically
modified crop and nobody's talked about
this crop in the u.s. our farmers know
it's there because we're growing it in
the Midwest already it's called Liberty
link and so it used to be Roundup Ready
crops from Monsanto but now it's Liberty
link from Bayer Liberty link is a creepy
enough name to it anyways but Liberty
link it turns out is a different genetic
modification to allow for a different
herbicide to be applied to the crop and
the mechanism of action is same concept
where it's blocking the production of
amino acid
which is the building blocks for life
but it's blocking a very specific one in
this case it blocks the enzyme that
makes gluten glutamine and and this this
happens to be an extremely important
piece of innumerable endocrine functions
innumerable functions of you know
cellular biology but most profoundly
perhaps is fertility human fertility to
pound this amino acid so this is the
this is the next evolution of roundup
this is the next evolution of GMO crops
and it's growing in your Midwest United
States right now and it's owned by Bayer
and so that got weird slice wheat it's
it's a corn soybean now going across
they can put it in any you know anything
they want and at this point I think but
it's the big staple crops that they're
growing corn and soybean particularly
but sugar beets and all those are well
on the way you know so but corn soybean
already being grown in the u.s. under
this new new crop treatment which is
blocking the ability of that food to
carry these essential amino acids into
the into the food chain so we have
simultaneous fronts on a fronts on our
soil systems and then we have the human
health impact of ingesting all of these
crops on a mass scale which is
disrupting our endocrine systems it's
destroying our microbiome like explain a
little bit about how this is leading to
all of these degenerative chronic
illnesses that we're seeing yeah so you
know I think to finish off that
political thought I just before my brain
can move on is it makes sense that if
you've got a new commodity that could
take over the majority of the world but
you're gonna in direct competition for
month with Monsanto who's already
mastered 85 and 90 percent of the farm
environment to make the move to purchase
that companies a no-brainer because it
gives you the opportunity to become you
know monopolies across both it's amazing
that you passed antitrust muster I don't
think it got even evaluated I don't
understand how somebody could have
honestly said they did an ant
evaluation I mean I think when we were
here before the when you were here
before the merger was pending but it
hadn't fully gone I thought I was gonna
fall because of the antitrust issues I
didn't think there was a way that it we
not only that I just assumed especially
because of our current administration
having such a nationalistic you know
agenda apparently I couldn't believe the
last time we talked that it was gonna be
allowed to go through because what
American president would want to have
that on their track record that they
allowed eighty five ninety percent of
art are commodity crops to be owned by a
foreign entity and it's patently
anti-competitive because there is no
competitor no competitor no competitor
and so how it could not have been
considered monopoly is beyond me I think
they must have found some loophole
around that issue of well we have to
feed the world I have a feeling that's
how they started through well what is
the lobbying budget of Monsanto or Bayer
for that matter the GDP of a small
European nation sure yeah and they're at
multiple levels right because it's not
just food to Mai's they're also also in
energy right because we've used up and
raped our most fertile soils in the
United States for the production of
ethanol for our cars and so Monsanto has
been playing on multiple sectors
politically and so they're not just food
and AG they're they're energy and you
know spread across into even military
budgets I'm sure because of the
provision of ethanol to the military so
and now it's Pharma and now it's farmer
and so you've and farmers not new to
Monsanto by the way pharmaco own
Monsanto although back in the 1990s and
so when that when we went to genetic
modification of crops we already were
own and our our food chain was already
owned by the pharmaceutical industry by
the time and so Monsanto has been owned
repetitively by the pharmaceutical
companies and so I think Bayer is making
the play now is a big pharmaceutical
company you own the global food chain
and make this weird play for Liberty
link it's just gluten you know we're
gonna block this amino acid so now why
have I never heard of that if they
purposely just not publicize that and
given it this jingoistic patriotic name
to make people feel good about it well I
think now I'm predicting the future and
I don't know and
but my prediction is we're gonna see a
whole bunch of killer cases now allowing
to go to case to go to court because I
think bear wants everybody to now admit
that that GMO roundup crops are terrible
for your health so they can pull it off
the market quicker and look like the
white knights coming in with liberty
legacy well you're absolutely right we
see you know Monsanto who refused to
tell you this but we own them now and
we're telling you our science and our
review of all of their data is saying
it's definitely causing cancer
we're sorry Mia culpa and that puts an
end on all of the voices setting aside
some crazy war chests to settle all
these cases they haven't I'm sure they
did because if I mean look at how much
they're making just off of GMO crops
that are still selling Monsanto seed and
so even if the sixty six billion bought
the company they can there they've got
the income to offset the court cases
with that they may have you know if you
looked at the amount of income expected
from Monsanto and multiply that by the
typical 5x for the valuation of their
company we might find that the war chest
was built right into that as a fudge
factor since they may have been worth
two hundred billion dollars and they
they sold for sixty six billion and said
hey we could pay a hundred billion
dollars of lawsuits and still at the end
of all that we pull that Monsanto GMO
crop off the market and we put Liberty
link in play and so they already have I
think there's no way a company and his
biggest Bears not gonna have an end game
in play when Monsanto is already all
tied up in these lawsuits
well the lobbying arm is certainly
healthy at this point I just got an
email today from ewg Environmental
Working Group it was a letter penned by
Erin Brockovich about how how the farm
bill that's uh that's up for renewal has
a provision in it that would allow
locality that would strip away the
purview of localities to ban glyphosate
yeah so this is still you know this is a
war that's being fought constantly on
multiple battle fronts yeah I mean I've
had people at the municipal level at
city levels begging for our science to
be taken to their local
school board to stop spraying the school
yard with Roundup you know and you know
are not are just our group there's
hundreds of scientists around the world
that are trying to help with this
mission but to see so much resistance
down there yeah I got a call a couple
weeks ago from this woman who was trying
to make this fight and they present all
this science to the school board and
they brought in a Monsanto sales rep to
to be there and the Monsanto's sales rep
just got or it pulled the Trump maneuver
it sounds like we're just got more and
more angry the whole time red-faced this
is foolish this this woman's uh you know
has no educational background she's
bringing all the science like she knows
what she's talking about baba doing this
and his final closing statement was
roundup is so safe that I would be happy
for my son to lick the grass right after
it's sprayed and so as a scientist
having looked at glyphosate that's child
abuse yeah
that's flat-out ridiculous statement
knowing what we know about this but that
emotional argument overcame everything
and schoolyard still being sprayed with
Roundup and so it's it's the
emotionality of the human brain that's
one of our biggest challenges right now
and so we also don't want to really
believe that this is going on on such a
mass scale like we want to just say
there's no way it could be that unsafe
we would never have allowed it to get to
this point we're smarter than that
certainly HEA the cover yelling the EPA
has looked at this there's been a
million trials everybody says it's safe
you guys are crazy conspiracy theorists
and I think that's been kind of the
paradigm for a long time and we are
seeing that shift you know people are
taking your point of view and the point
of view of so many scientists that are
allied with your perspective in a way
that we weren't seeing even a couple
years ago and I think that court case
you know goes a long way towards letting
credence to what's actually happening I
totally agree and I think the the
snowball is rolling and that's why we've
seen this transaction for Monsanto
debayer I think that the public
sentiment as
Papa continues to educate itself more
and more through you know open channels
will realize that we've known this for a
long time and it's no different than the
tobacco situation was in the 1960s to
2000 that forty years scientists were
trying to sue the tobacco companies for
lung cancer and for the damage to kids
immune systems and you know all kinds of
horrible things for 40 years that we
were at it you know with the data
coked-out is our product and you know it
was that emotional thing of like well
tobacco's how we built our nation you
know the deep south and everything else
like it was part of the Americana the
Marlboro Man was the the image of
American strength and so it was so
entwined in our psyche and in our
identity that it took a long time to
untangle that in the same way our
identity is so tangled up around this
belief that we are the best food growers
in the world and so to dismantle that
belief that humility that it takes to
say we're growing the worst food on the
planet the least nutrient delivery of
any food system in the world perhaps the
only other place where we see were that
where South Cummins nutritionally our
people that just can't get access to
food period and I want to bring it to
that because again this argument that
keeps coming up in the world of what we
have to feed seven billion people so we
have to do chemical farming hay crop
yields decline not increase when you do
long term chemical farming be one of the
great farmers that were working with in
the Midwest now know hiyo he says today
in the world seventy percent of humans
of the seven billion people on the
planet are fed by a peasant farmer hmm
and that's humbling mm-hmm you know if
only 30 percent of humanity is actually
eating from a large-scale farm then what
is the hubris that we need organic or
non-organic chemical farming to feed the
world so what is preventing these
farmers from making this switch it seems
like they're they're aware that their
yields are going down they have some you
know sense that this is not working is
it because they're locked in through
debt structures that they can't escape
this paradigm to do it another way
death structure 100% yes but there's
something more insidious at play that we
didn't understand until we were on the
ground with these farmers is that in any
culture and in the state where you know
85 to 90 percent of the ground is under
chemical farming there is a collective
subconscious agreement or contract
socially in that farm community that you
don't talk about this you certainly
don't tell anybody that your crop yield
has been decreasing for 15 years you
certainly don't tell anybody that you
think chemical farming is hurting your
children and causing the birth defects
that you're seeing in your kids and
certainly you know we've seen the most
redness of disease happening on these
farms these farmers families are so sick
major brain malformations and these
children that are being born while their
father you know had this tearful father
come up to me when I was giving the talk
the science talk on roundup in Minnesota
was in in July and he and his wife came
up right after my talk and by this time
was dark we were out a field when I was
giving this talk in a field and the
birds had settled us down and it was
like crickets at night and it was a
bucolic stuff but the the tension in the
dark with all these farmers are about
100 farmers sitting around in the dark
listening to this and they came up in
the dark and said you know you just
answered the biggest question but we
have to ask this just straight to you is
that the week that we conceived our
child I was spraying roundup and I was
literally drenched in and I was my
clothes that come in in the evenings and
I was covered and everything else and
our child was born with this defect
where it has no connection between left
and right hemispheres of the brain and
so he's very has all these developmental
delays and has difficulty walking and
all these things that he'll have to face
the rest of his life do you think it's
possible that and me being a covered
with chemicals throughout that that
those weeks previous to conception I did
my sperm or her egg or do that damage
happened due to the chemical exposure
and just you know being present and
saying you know just like the lung
cancer we don't need to put the
responsibility on this second of your
action with glyphosate but what we can
say as
population this is exactly what's
happening all of us under the pressure
of the chemicals and so the farmers are
not it's not theoretical for them it's
not a banking problem they have a
collapse of their own family are in
infrastructure going on their children
have attention deficit allergies asthma
some many of the farmers that have
children under the age of teenagers who
we talked to won't let their kids out
during the summer because the plains
spray are flying over all day long
spraying their neighbours crops and
their crops and everything else and so
then if their kids go out they've got
asthma there have breathing problems by
the evening that little eyes or
bloodshot because they're just so much
chemical in the air and so the kids are
here we think of this bucolic farmland
kids running around in the countryside
they're locked in these you know you
know mildew filled trailers basically
all summer long trying to survive the
chemical warfare that's happening around
them throughout the summer growing
months then so you've got this financial
lock-in with the banks you've got health
collapse happening in the family
you've got the emotional tension of I
have to look at my dad every day and
tell him that we're losing the farm that
he's had since his great-grandfather
farmed this land you got all this
emotional family tension and then on top
of that you have the the community
pressure the peer pressure and so if you
decide to make the jump and stop
chemical spraying and go to a
regenerative agriculture you're
immediately socially ostracized nobody
will talk to your church nobody's
talking you at the bar nobody's talking
to the bank because just by making that
jump you just made a judgment call on
everybody else Wow that's the person
yeah I I wouldn't have even thought we
didn't even think of it yeah and at to
the last farm when we talked to that's
the biggest number one reason they won't
go regenerative AG is they have no
community and even if they did or they
could if they could break free of the
debt structure if they could navigate
the you know social landmines that are
involved in that they're dealing with a
plot of land that's been depleted thus
they would have to regenerate the soil
before they could even conceivably grow
anything in an organic manner right like
yes short of move
finding already in our arsenal it's a
it's a burden that that that I would
imagine is just too unmanageable they
can't see the way out because the
chemical industry has told them that it
takes more than 10 years to build half a
centimeter of soil so to regenerate half
a centimeter to a centimeter or soil as
I said 10 years well they're losing
inches of soil a year we're in the
biggest Dust Bowl in history right now
and how much of that can be is
attributable to chemicals versus just
mono cropping and not allowing you know
not not rotating crops and all of these
other abilities yeah the over tilling is
as equally as damaging to the soil
architecture as the spray that's quite
clear and so we can't just be organic
certified that's not enough we have to
go to regen AG standards where we
actually build soil
not till soil and so we hadn't need to
go to a no-till organic technique and
this is being taught all over the
country by some very intrepid farmers
who are out there they've converted over
a million acres quietly over the last
decade 15 years until regenerative
agricultural practices no-till no spray
that is the Promised Land for how we get
ourselves out of this situation so we
went to shoot a documentary series when
we came back knowing we had to start a
non-profit we needed to get money into
these farmers environments and more
importantly than money we needed that
money to build an architecture for a new
community if these farmers have
community and they can talk to each
other and say okay the six of us are
going to make the jump mm-hmm they can
now talk to each other daily they can
now you know compare notes at the end of
every week that I think is the secret we
have so we've launched a nonprofit and
we're in the process of our 501 C 3
we're partnering with another Virginia
group to go ahead and start taking money
in for the operation the next couple
weeks
it's called farmers footprint the
website's farmers footprint us and the
mission here is to tie consumers back to
the agricultural land itself with the
goal of converting five million acres of
farmland that's currently under GMO
chemical farming back to not just
organic but exceed that with this new
no-till no spray
mandate and we're gonna do it through a
number of different fashions certainly
the docu-series that we're creating
farmers footprint is there to educate us
as consumers is what is the plight of
the farmer how do we come alongside that
group to create a viable solution now we
haven't even touched on the farm bill
and how that's playing in for the last
40 years into farming practices and is
yet another barrier to success and so
we've we've decided that if we can bring
a hundred dollars per acre from the
consumers into the farmers environment
we can overcome the farm bill we can
overcome this banking juggernaut and
hopefully we build that community to
allow the farmers to overcome this
ostracized status that they get from
making the jump and so a farmer's
footprint is seen you know that
operating that so what do we see
actually happens so does no-till nor
non-organic or no spray actually work
like you said these farmers are looking
at dead dead soil one of the things that
I have the highest conviction over now
as a scientist is the concept of grace
in biology I grew up in kind of a
Christian environment and kind of hippie
church and Boulder and great people
around and so I had kind of a lexicon of
kind of a relatively open-minded church
doctrine and the word grace got through
and thrown around in this faith
community all the time and now I'm
supposed to a lot of people from all
types of spiritual backgrounds and going
to the Muslim or the Buddhists or their
Jewish community hear this word grace
with a different frequency but it's out
there in our lexicon I think it can Moby
maybe boast best be defined now in my
mind at least scientifically which is
heal faster than you injury and that's
what we see in the soil and that's what
I get to see my clinic I see people who
have abused their bodies for decades and
if they just give a pause they do a
couple of short-term fasts they give
their gut a break they give their immune
system a break they get away from
chemicals they start growing some of
their own food and make these simple
little decisions and suddenly decades of
damage is reversed in hours weeks months
that's grace at the cellular level and
there may be a better spiritual the
definition of
ecology standpoint I see grace as you're
going to make mistakes
and you're gonna heal fast or from them
when you when you make the change and
that's what we see in the soil and so
these farmers who are making the jump
again we've seen a million acres make
this transition and so soil health
Academy is our partners in this group
and they're for phenomenal farmers who
really are have been cutting the edge of
this this no-till no spray effort and
what we're seeing is that within a
single growing season you can go from
this dead monoculture of corn or soybean
to cover cropping with 16 different
species and getting a no-till
environment you'll see the fungal
elements you'll see the micro micro rise
a in there the bacterial populations
returning the soil and you see
biodiversity returning in the form of
earthworms within a single growing
season of rest yeah it's the
environmental planetary version of what
you just explained in the human body
it's fat right yeah fast for just a
moment stop doing the damage for just a
short bit resiliency is amazing it's
amazing and it would have to be there's
a book recently out I'm gonna screw up
the title I think it's something like
earth without humans or something like
this and it describes how fast the
ecosystem is gonna recover when we
disappear in for government it describes
New York City two weeks without humans
and you see every element of the the
concrete infrastructure of Manhattan
disappearing under biology uh-huh and
within two months and two years and you
see how fast life leaps out of this
planet and it has to be that way because
it's Mother Earth uh-huh that's how we
got here this finite plan has been
exploding with life for millions of
millions of years before Homo sapiens
showed up we got to combat this problem
I mean one of the things that we talked
about last time that was so shocking for
me to hear was just the pervasiveness of
of chemical spraying so even if you are
an organic farmer or you are consumer
buying organic or you're trying to
you know live in a clean environment
that glyphosate and various other
chemicals are so pervasive they found
their way into our drinking water it's
in the rain water it's raining down onto
these organic farms so despite trying to
hermetically remove ourselves from this
problem it's it's still you know
something that we have to contend with
even when we're doing everything in our
power to avoid it I mean I know that's
one of the reasons that you move to a
remote location in Virginia was to try
to find a pristine place to live and
have a family yeah yeah it's getting
hard right it's getting hard to find
anything that would be considered
Pristina in the world let alone the US
but I think it is I mean first of all
why is that why is glyphosate everywhere
it's the nature of the molecule itself
it's an amino acid backbone with a
phosphate group and a carbon group on
the other end and you get this thing
called an organophosphate and
organophosphates in this form are
extremely water-soluble 70% of earth is
water and it turns out that 70% of your
body is water and so we've put into play
a chemical that is water-soluble that
can now travel through all levels of the
water ecosystem and so in the
evaporating water coming off the
Mississippi River as we collect some 80
percent of all the roundup sprayed in
our country into a single water system
through the what runoff that happens
when we water or when the rain falls or
whatever it is we consolidate that into
the great muddy and it shouldn't be
muddy but it's carrying all of our
topsoil in it now because all of our
topsoil is dead and was routing away an
amazing estimate on that actually I just
read that eleven percent of our GDP is
being wasted every year in topsoil
the amount of monetary loss from our
topsoil washing away is equal to 11
percent of GDP because it's so unhealthy
that it doesn't it here exactly
yeah there's no root structure to keep
it there there's no my my crew right
mycorrhizae there's no mycelium there's
no fungal structure in the soil to keep
the topsoil where it needs to be and so
every time it rains the rain can't even
penetrate the soil which is ridiculous
it's so hard that the water when it
finally rains on your crop
can't get into the soil and said it
takes the top centimeter of your soil
away and washes it to the nearest gully
and out into the water system which of
course ends up in a Mississippi River
and then into the Delta and at the end
of the Mississippi River we now have a
dead zone that's larger than the state
of Rhode Island because there's so much
herbicide pesticide and chemical
fertilizer in that water and so we've
got this huge dead zone in the ocean
right at the mouth of the Mississippi
and not a single politician was talking
about that dumbfounding that we can be
this myopic um so soil is disappearing
all of this is broken yes justice yes
but I still want to bring it back to the
simple reality as the the brokenness in
the system has to do with the isolation
of human relationship if we connect the
farmer back to the consumer and we cut
out the banks we cut out the farm bill
we cut out the big chemical industry
that's that's trying to educate them
incorrectly we have a cut on all those
players the amount of money we save is
extraordinary first of all but the
amount of money we can bring into those
lands is extraordinary so there's such a
huge economic incentive right now for
farmers to make this jump they just need
support for about three years to make
the transition because after three to
five years they can take crop yields
right now if they're under GMO crop they
can expect to yield maybe forty bucks an
acre after they subtract out all their
inputs and everything else so typical
family farm you're growing maybe 300
acres of corn soybean some mix thereof
300 acres times your 40 dollars you're
at a dismal annual income and to achieve
that you've woken up every morning at
4:00 a.m. you go to sleep at 10:00 p.m.
you cry yourself to sleep every night
your your relationship with your wife is
so stressed because she's yelling that
change has to happen cuz the kids are
sick she has had money to pay the health
bills can't fill the pharmacy
prescriptions dad's chomping at you
because you know you must be doing
something wrong so it's not working you
need to change and for that you get your
your dismal you know dish
to just service the debt services the
debt right and so then you have to
borrow money to buy the seed to buy the
fertilizers for your next crop and
you're back in the cycle again and so
this is the reality for so many of these
farms and you know I just have to be
amazed at the economic incentive on the
other side of this is these farms and
these don't over a million acres that
have made the transition back to region
AG over the last 15 years
these guys are senior returns per acre
of 500 to 900 dollars an acre from $40
40 oh my god and so it's we want to
believe that there's some impossible way
it's too hard to get you know money for
organic food no it's so much more
lucrative these farmers they could be
the most lucrative generation of farmers
in their entire family if they can get
to rihgina practice and and what you
said earlier is that to make that
transition costs about $100 per acre in
order to kind of help these people make
that switch yeah and and the hundred
dollars it doesn't even need to go to
being a safety net income entirely so
the third of it we see going to their
education a third of it we see going to
consumer education and then a third of
it we see becoming a safety net income
for them or they not mine get paid but
we say if you were to fail because
that's their fear if I don't do what
I've been doing in the last 15 or 20
years of chemicals my crop next year is
gonna fail and I'm gonna go bankrupt so
we don't need to give them an income
necessarily but what we can say is look
you know we've now raised enough private
funds for you that we can give you a
safety net that says if you're actually
in this transition of no-spray no-till
and you happen to fail one of those
years we can get we'll meet you at 42
all there's an acre right we'll meet you
there you can't draw you you will not go
down an income that's what we need to do
is create that safe - right right right
that's safety net I don't think is he
mean have to be tapped into because the
farmers that are making the transition
are already seeing improved yields year
one of going back to a non GMO seed on
the same plot of land same plot of land
no-till no spray a non GMO seed and
suddenly they're back to 40 bushels an
acre that's
so you're making this documentary or
docu-series
like how FAR's to do it are you and what
is the plan for that because to me this
is an education thing it seems like
right like the more people can
understand what is actually going on we
can create a groundswell of support for
these farmers my goal is that by the end
of 2019 we'll have three of the
docu-series wrapped by then the first
one's been all shot we're in post with
that one should be out by January of
2019 as we debut that docu-series I
don't think it's going to take any
imagination that's a 30 minute
docu-series each element 30 minutes so
it's easy digestion when you meet these
farmers and see the passion and desire
in their eyes and in their hearts to do
the right thing here we need to stop
damming the farmer first the farmers are
the biggest heroes I've ever met I have
never met a more resilient courageous
group of human beings in my life my
brothers in the military I think I would
have said that about the military right
up until I met the farmers so I have
huge respect for for anybody in any
military in any part of the world those
are courageous human beings that do some
of the worst of the worst
however the farmers I think have been
locked in a chemical warfare that's
nylons well we did in Vietnam as far as
the amount of planetary damage times 10
or times 100 or times 1,000 and so these
guys have been locked as the brute force
to destroy nature and they know it on
some level they all know it and and
that's why they have to ostracize each
other when somebody comes to the light
it's because it it immediately convicts
everybody else and there's this huge
guilt that that's riding underneath the
surface these farmers are a change
though and to see you know the success
where you know you can see it on our
trailer on our website and the farmers
footprint allen and i williams is one of
the PhDs
it was soil health academy and he tells
the story that you know ten years ago
they couldn't put ten farmers in a room
in the entire country that could have
cared about regenerative agriculture
now they do health academies all year
round all over the country and they
they've got 6,200 farmers in every
single room and so
there's an inevitable demand happening a
grassroots well as you said from the
farmers if we don't meet them though as
consumers right there at that moment in
the field it's going to take too long it
could be 30 50 years before we see
enough people convert over to AG the
amazing thing though is here we are
laying out a recipe for success for a
region of agriculture and recovering
soil health if we convert five million
acres we solve greenhouse gas problems
in North America we will absorb water
less grass gases than we produce and so
every acre of land the largest co2
consumer in it is the phone fungal
community within the soil layer we have
global warming because we depleted the
vast majority of soil on earth where I
think we're down to 2% of irritable land
is now viable still we've killed 98
percent of the soil on earth and that's
China to the US to Africa we've killed
it if you just google this actually the
you know big AG community will follow
depleted soil records and so you can see
like satellite kind of map images of
where the depleted soil patterns are
throughout the world and the Midwest the
United States is one of the most pleased
areas worldwide and so you then didn't
track that with with global warning
patterns and the single biggest producer
of greenhouse gases is methane actually
there are the biggest contributor
interestingly by volume by kind of cubic
meters of methane and it's only about
15% of global greenhouse gas but it's
six times more potent than co2 as a
greenhouse gas and so as its impact on
biology and around on global warming
methane is number one enemy interesting
methane is primarily produced through
the AG industry mm-hmm and so it's
through and through cattle farm and
cattle farms but primarily through poor
management of the soil and the crops
they're on one of the biggest producers
of methane is actually the decaying
slowly rotting piles of sugar beet cane
that we have throughout the south I do
not know that so that's called bagasse
that by-product we have seen piles of
bagasse that
in the billions of pounds sighs they
they take up you know city city city
blocks you drive along these huge Street
and long dusty roads down through
Alabama Louisiana Mississippi and the
piled as high as you can imagine as a
massive piles of sugarcane that don't
compost well and so they just sit there
in these giant piles under the Sun and
off gas methane sugar beets are have
zero role in human nutrition there's no
piece of the sugar beet that's a good
human being the sugar industry has been
producing that since you know the 50s as
a primary crop and it turns out they
most come on
subsidized crop in the farm bill is the
sugar beet it's gotten so dismal growing
corn and soybean in Minnesota and the
and the North where we have all these
rich soils that they're actually now
intentionally destroying the soil
structure so that it can be poor enough
to grow sugar beet in sugar beet likes
poor soil and so we have farmers that
are killing their soil intentionally so
that they can get subsidized $100 on the
acre to grow sugar beets in Minnesota
should have never been grown so the
incentivization structure is wrong it's
backwards going both ways always every
single structure that we have to support
big AG in this country is forcing the
farmers hand into poor agriculture and
biologic decisions can we combat this
problem without overhauling the farm
bill I mean that seems to be front and
center of you know a large percentage of
what's gone awry yeah and if you'd asked
me 10 years ago that was my focus like
when I was thinking about nutrition in
the late 2000s I thought well we just
need to fix the farm bill and this
money's gonna be over in a day I've
given up on that I've seen the most
disparate political positions you know
between you know Bush to to Obama to you
know now this amazing journey of Trump
not a single whisper of a change in the
farm bill going on and so I've given up
on that transformation that's why we're
creating farmers footprint with the
realization is actually even if we
revised for the farm bill it's not a big
enough single incentive to change the
way things are done
we literally need to cut out all the
middlemen if we cut out all the
middlemen ie the banks alone that are
charging these incredible interest rates
to farmers if you just remove the
interest rates that are costing our
farmers to grow their food we are gonna
see a very lucrative shift happen and so
my belief is we need to cut on all the
middlemen
get the farmer connected to the to the
consumer directly and we'll see an
economic manage so much larger than the
current farm bill that we don't need to
fix the farm bill but it's literally a
private sector capitalistic solution
yeah the problem but if sugar beets are
so lucrative
and so incentivized and will literally
grow anywhere in terrible soil how are
we going to overcoming the desire the
market desire for that product is
astronomical and if it's such a large
contribute in to greenhouse gas
emissions we have to create
disincentives for that do we not
I don't think so better incentives for
them to grow something cuz if we can
make five hundred nine hundred dollars
an acre doing regenerative ass so what's
the yield from from sugar beets and
you're down around $100 an acre or
something like that you know typically
and it's gonna vary depending on where
you are and there's you know the farm
bill is the most complicated piece of
legislation we have so to say it's $100
makers overly simplistic but it's not in
an economic level that we can't overcome
it if it wasn't at such a high economic
benefit that five years ago everybody up
north was growing sugar beet they had to
get into such a desperate level with the
corn and soy bean yields that they
started you know this new practice of
dead soil or killing the soil further to
to grow the sugar beet so you know I
think I'm encouraged at the end of the
day that we can put into play a free
market capitalist exclusion the concept
of a non-profit here is just accelerate
the farmer to it
you know give them a safety net for
those few years they need I would love
to see the situation where in a few
years we have corporations coming along
farmers to say we would like to buy up a
million acres and we're gonna pay you to
do no-till regen AG on it you know and
that's that's the switch that I think is
coming because right now we have all
these fortune 500 companies that are
the world and buying co2 offsets well
the co2 offset of an acre of regen AG
could offset you know way more you know
bang for the buck and so I think that if
our companies can start to recognize
soil is their number one co2 sink then
our air lines for example need to be the
number one investor in soils in the
Midwest and be working directly with
these farmers to make lucrative
situations for the farmer and mass of
co2 dumps for the industry you made an
interesting point before we start at the
podcast I mean clearly what we're
talking about this is this is in our
economic interest it is a not it is in
the interest of human health environment
global environmental health but there's
also this additional point about
national security so explain that yeah
so I mean I think the national security
threat if if you haven't started to see
it in the course this conversation we
can kind of point out those elements too
but but what an extraordinary thing so
extraordinary slippage of our concept of
monopolies to allow one company down 90%
of our you know crop our staple crops
which is affecting our fuel everything
from our fuel production for the energy
sector to our big AG which of course
feeds the fish the chickens the pork the
the beef those who huge industries all
being fed the GMO commodities and so
huge huge control of this massive
massive industry of human food and then
to make the move where you allow a
German company regulated in a completely
different environment than anything in
the u.s. now outside the regulatory
control really of the u.s. makes the
move to purchase this country I think
it's again one of those most myopic
things if the world works like we think
it does now that I've seen this thing
actually come to fruition which I really
didn't think was getting the government
was gonna allow to happen I have to
wonder if maybe that international scene
and the relationship between the US
government and the EU and these other
big factions are must be a little
different than we thought there must be
some back room agreements happening
across the world as to what what
the powers-that-be would like the world
food chain to look like in 20 years and
they're making some sort of geopolitical
decisions based on something much bigger
than the United States of America yeah
well Europe historically has been more
much more resistant to the use of
glyphosate and GMO crops and as much has
been then more progressive in terms of
being Pro organic but we're seeing that
start to slip away a little bit
huge erosion time yeah and we have GMO
crops in every European country that's
why France has to say well mate by 2020
we're gonna be non GMO I'll say you're
not gonna be non to remember the future
means our GMO right now
and so even these countries that we
think of as being clean are not at all
clean and it's not just glyphosate and
that's my concern if we make this just
an argument over glyphosate then Bayer
just simply presents Liberty link and
see we're glyphosate free mm-hmm so now
France gets to say work life stay free
or whatever it is if they really hold
the line and say we're gonna be GMO free
and they can hold that line not just you
know quoting Anik but their their GMO
free that would be an interesting shift
because now that you've got contention
within the EU of what what the European
regulatory body that's equal to what we
would call the EPA here has already
proved Liberty Lake so we'll start to
see some huge court battles I think
between the the nation-states of the EU
and the big EU regulatory bodies and
bear over these next year's to battle
that out and see where that goes I still
have hope because there's economic
incentive that is massive there's
hundreds of trillions of dollars over
the next 30 to 50 years that could be
made by an intelligent approach to this
process and so the right answers are
lucrative and that gives me hope but
there still has to be political will and
the the strategy of trying to go
top-down
for example tackling the farm bill have
proved non fruitful so now the focus is
more on a bottom-up incentive IDs
incentivizing these farmers and creating
a groundswell of popular support for
this to then exert some pressure on the
on the top levels on the legislative
level on the
Nitori level and on the political level
absolutely and and and for whatever
concerns we might throw on the air here
in a podcast around the loss of freedom
and security for the United States as we
sell-off our our you know staple crop
production we have just as much
opportunity to give the beautiful
picture of what if the United States
became the most resilient and deeply
rooted agricultural land in the world
that no matter what drought hits us no
matter what happens and we're gonna have
such resilience in such redundancy
within our farmland that we become food
independent and so the cat phrase that
farmers footprint is a pathway to human
health and food independence mmm-hmm
because food independence needs to be
the political mission if we create food
independence greenhouse gas problems go
away
we will absorb all that co2 and methane
we will stop producing so much co2 and
methane we will fix that problem and so
my message is one of real empowerment to
the the heartland of the United States
are you a farmer right now do you know a
farmer if you don't know a farmer meet
one and and become part of the most
important American thing we'll ever do
it's time for us to rebrand and we've
done this many times as a country you
know we were American land of the free
we've been land of Liberty we've been
you know we've had all these you know
clever catchphrases that she didn't
change out every generation or two in
the United States land of the fed I
don't know land of the healthy land of
thrive you know what are we going to
rebrand as Russia's doing it folks and
you know you you can have whatever
geopolitical viewpoint you want but if
Russia succeeds in being organic
agriculture by 2025 they've got us beat
in spades they just have to wait ten
more years for us to financially
completely collapse ourselves with our
brenda's health problems and they're
gonna win this this economic battle on
the big big picture here keep in mind
China's not going to say what yeah
what's going on in China right now it's
the rendus situation in China and China
makes more glyphosate than Monsanto ever
did you know glyphosate as a molecule
went off patent in 2007 and the vast
on the international market is now made
out of China China has the highest rates
of pre-diabetes in cancer in the world
and they aren't publishing that stuff
and so I really believe that the The
Smoking Gun in Western civilization
right now nobody understands I think and
maybe I'm completely naive because I'm
just a doctor but I think that the
biggest player in Western economics is
China and we don't it is not an Eastern
force it's a full-on Western force now
perhaps in the 1980s and early 90s you
could call it an eastern economic force
but they diversified all of their money
into the West and so they owned the vast
majority of gold and minerals and all
that that gold rights through South
America and Africa through the
throughout the West and so they are an
economic power from the West from my
viewpoint I would say Russia the Eastern
Bloc maybe parts of northern Africa are
what are kind of the eastern you know
autonomy now and so you've you've got
this situation where the eastern economy
that now becomes dominated in the next
15 years as China and the US collapse in
our health care and that and Russia
Rises maybe that's gonna happen if we
don't change direction it's also strange
to contemplate that it's so strange that
I think nobody can take it seriously I
think you know people are listening this
right now blowing off everything ever
said in either these podcasts is like
Zak sounds completely crazy now because
that's a jump where you can't imagine
that you know in our mindset Russia's
got this you know backwards economy and
everything else and the corruption sure
but no we're worse than I think what
we've cut and so many levels of our
government here so but they made this
call they said the most important thing
for national security of Russia is go
GMO free organic food make real food by
2025 and we'll win the game and if we
don't step up and and meet that call
we're gonna lose the economic game there
was an article some time in the last
month a couple a bunch of articles came
out about this study that came out of
the EU about the the deleterious impact
of glyphosate on the bee populations did
you see this yes and the reason I bring
it up
because I don't want this to be all
about glyphosate like you said but it
goes back to how we kind of originally
opened this which is that the earth and
humans are holistic systems that are
interdependent and if it is indeed true
if there's some validity to the fact
that glyphosate or these other chemicals
are are responsible for the depopulation
of of bees we're seeing the beginnings
or perhaps the the adolescence of a
cataclysmic you know house of cards
falling in upon itself where it becomes
difficult if not impossible to to stop
to arrest like once this starts to
happen how much of it then becomes
self-perpetuating and difficult for us
to put the brakes on because so many
things are obviously dependent upon what
the what the bees are doing you know
where are we with that and they're
absolutely right and and this does kind
of bring us back full circle where I was
kind of pointing out you know you may
think you found yourself to an itch
that's going to survive this onslaught
of human health chronic disease you know
all this stuff but the fact is we now
know that your your health is not
independent you can't be independently
healthy as a family and we're in the
sixth great extinction on the planet
right now there's been five other great
extinctions in the fossil record on our
planet it's been 60 million years since
our last great one with the dinosaur
collapse and everything else which I
happen to be a destruction of the
topsoil which is interesting really so
the Tahoe because of that the ash that
covered that dust layer that covered the
planet killed the topsoil we had this
huge collapse of the ecosystem and so
here we are back destroying the topsoil
and seeing the sixth extinction happened
we're losing one species to the point of
extinction every twenty minutes now and
so in the course I think you said we've
lost 50% of the Earth's biodiversity in
the last 4050 years you know so 40% of
the biodiversity on earth gone in 50
years is the current estimates with one
species disappearing every 20 minutes in
the course of our conversation hey we've
law
three or four species that we don't even
know how to name we don't know who they
were but they disappeared and the bees
are a perfect example of that we're
seeing we are pushing our bee population
to the point of extinction they're
really being kept in line and a lot of
parts of the country by ship by moving
bees in on trucks and so we have these
huge trucks that are moving beehives
around the country to go pollinate you
know the almond trees in Southern
California or you know the staple crops
in the Midwest where we've killed all
the bee population and so we have are
driving this these bees there and I
don't think Einstein may have been the
one to coin the term or coined the the
quote but he's been credited with it and
in the 1930s saying and that humans will
survive for about three years after the
bees are gone I don't know who was the
clairvoyant guy to come up with that it
was probably a woman who was nurturing
enough to come up with that at the time
and it got got Gibbon Einstein there but
whoever said you know really understood
the role of these these pollinating
species in the human survival and
amazingly this is being talked about a
lot in in academia and and the
technology circles is that we we can't
survive the loss of the bees and so one
of the most astounding examples of our
our hubris again as I articles have come
out in the last couple years saying the
solution for the future of humanity is
these robotic bees and so there's
building these little drone bees that
are supposed to replace bees and
pollinators and that's our solution I
mean that's just a classic example of
what we're seeing all over the place I
think there's a there's a level of
apathy and and powerlessness that most
people feel and it's convenient and
comforting to think that you know Elon
Musk is just gonna innovate us out of
whatever problem that we have we're
gonna go colonize Mars when we can't
even figure out how to properly
terraform our own planet right this idea
that we're we're divesting ourselves of
responsibility and just looking past to
the next opportunity or the next
technological breakthrough and we can
all go to sleep at night you know
comfort it by that but the truth is like
the
is not the way forward yes it's not the
way forward and if we don't reconnect to
nature we'll just destroy it again I
want to I want to try to bring this to
some sort of closure that doesn't feel
like I'm the most depressing person
you've ever listened to you and so I'm
kind of battling in my mind now to kind
of get us back to this space where we
can say it is doomsday unbridled
optimism like I don't really know where
you don't know where to go at this one
um so let me take you back to kind of
where how do you reconcile those two
things and I do it actually through my
experience as a physician in the ICUs
and in the icy use when I was practicing
intensive Hospital medicine I got the
privilege of being around human beings
at the end of life and I was so
compelled by this experience that I
ended up getting another subspecialty in
hospice and palliative care and dealing
with end-of-life things for for four
years with a hospice group and at the
end of a life we've termed it death and
what I've laid out for you today is the
possibility of the death of our species
in 70 years 100 years who cares it was
200 years it's still pathetic and so we
have we're looking at the last chapter
of life on Earth with our current course
of action but let me tell you about what
my experience has been in those last
moments with patients who are dying we
have the belief I think in our
subconscious because of the movies you
watch because of the TV shows we watch
because of our our big divorce from the
death process it's become sterilized you
a have probably not seen many people die
you've probably not seen your loved ones
die they've probably died you know
operating rooms or a nice use or and
they died before you could fly across
the country and see them or be and so
very few human beings are now watching
this process of of death and it's
allowed death to be defined as an
endpoint as a contraction or
disappearance rather than what I would
have actually seen it to be and what
I've seen it to be is a massive
expansion of consciousness of reality of
awareness and ultimately of love
and the most poignant examples of this
or people that actually die biologically
and we spend 15 or 30 minutes and ICU
resuscitating them with drugs and
shocking their chests like you see on TV
shows and everything else and we have a
dismal track record of pulling those
people act it's not like TV we lose the
vast majority its around 6 percent of
cardiac arrests and in the hospital will
actually be resuscitated and 6 percent
will survive 94 percent will die so you
have somebody who's now biologically
dead in your artificially sustaining
life we've got them on a respirator and
you're pounding on their chest and press
and you're pumping drugs in their vein
to try to get their heart restarted and
doing all of this and they've meanwhile
been in the ICU for a week or a few days
or weeks months in some cases before
they they have this moment and by this
time they've been isolated away from
humans for quite some time they're only
touched by latex gloves hands
only people with gowns on will come and
see them that masks on they haven't seen
a human face close up in months you know
they're so isolated and lonely and they
go into this moment on the other side
and and then we start working on them
and doing our code and and as the hero
depicted on TV
you become that doctor that pulls
somebody back from that that other side
of the veil and it was startling as you
know I moved past my internship and
started be kind of senior resident ease
in vironment sand really responsible for
being around these these patients for
hours after these experiences they all
told such a similar story on the other
side of biologic life and I had to do
with that a little bit of a typical
story that you said might see in the
movies or something where they saw a
white light and there's a sense of
expansion all this but there's one
sentence that that came back again and
again and I had one ICU shift that was
very weird I had the one ICU shift where
I worked for 36 hours shift and during
that that night and middle of my 36-hour
shift I see three people die and I bring
them all back when I sum up my team and
to the last one of those three every
single one of them their first sentence
had was always why did you bring me back
which always kind of deflated Molly and
said that yeah they
I said why did you bring me back and and
the variety was huge one of these was an
african-american pastor had had over 200
visitors in his ICU room in the days
before he passed away and the other one
was you know this very isolated kind of
ostracized
gentleman in his communities I was dying
of complications of AIDS and then I had
this kid he was who had genetic defects
and all this stuff and he was dying of
complications of pneumonia because he
couldn't breathe that anymore because
his skeleton to clout so you just
couldn't pick three different medical
cases or three different human beings
and every one of them first sentence
why'd you bring me back and then as they
start to get oriented and in the in the
hours that follow they're telling their
loved ones I went into this space and it
was bright white light everywhere and I
in that moment felt completely accepted
for the first time in my life and that
was a unexpected sentence to hear out of
multiple accounts I felt completely
accepted for the first time in my life
so what do you make of that I think
we're all walking around lonely and as
hell and our opportunity to rebirth
because death is not not an endpoint
it's an transformation moment it's an
expansion beyond the limits of this
frail biologic shell that we carry
around and the instant that we step out
of that we find out that the universe
embraces us in every single second of
our existence in complete acceptance of
who we are we are enough in and of our
own identity of I am at every second of
every point of our existence and it's
the disbelief of that that's keeping us
locked in these stupid conversations we
just had for last hour and a half that
is myopic conversation in and of itself
when you back up for a moment say okay
we're killing ourselves but what if we
need a death moment to transform
completely to let go of all of the
preconceived notions of what it is to be
human and to say you know what we are
beings of light and we are completely
accepted at every mode including this
moment when we would rape the earth of
what it were raping you know when we
would kill each other at the rate we do
when
would destroy the entire ecosystem of a
green planet in the middle of black
space when we would have that level of
hubris we're still completely accepted
and our journey is somehow understood by
something more benevolent and more
complete than we can see as human beings
and so let's not beat each other up over
this issue let's not see this as a
failure let's see this is an obvious
next step in our journey and death is
the inevitable thing marching at us
that's going to say are you going to
wake up and see the transformation at
that moment of death and transformation
and you're going to say goodbye Homo
sapiens we're gonna do it a moment
before that in the body before the
doctor starts the resuscitation are you
gonna say you know what what if we all
looked at each other in wonder and awe
and said you're enough I accept you
completely I want to be with you I want
to live with you I want to be a live
period and if it's with you then it must
be on purpose because we're in the same
room and the odds of that is zero and so
we are here seven billion of us showed
up right now which is really odd because
I just laid out a horrific story of
what's happening on the planet and yet
seven billion of those white souls that
seconds after death are going to realize
that they are who they've always been
they're fully accepted and they are
moving in true love and and that white
light is the love and they're in that
space what if we can transform before we
die then there's no reason to go to Mars
there's no reason to go anywhere else
because we will do absolutely every
single thing differently here on earth
and we're do it differently by just that
simple recognition of I am Who I am you
are who you are that's enough and I
accept you completely and let's figure
out how to do this within the design of
nature there's enough energy there's
enough food there's enough soil there's
enough commodities there's enough
resources for everybody on the planet to
thrive at a level that's never been
experienced turi we cannot continue any
form of human economic systems that have
ever existed before and expect us to
escape the death moment we literally
have to reinvent everything and so if
you are under the
age of 18 right now you are the last
generation that may live to the fullest
extent of the human potential it is you
who are being called it's transformed
because you showed up right when you did
if my generation is to do anything it
was to say oh my gosh we're going in the
wrong direction but my generation
doesn't have enough time now to turn the
boat around and reinvent everything and
so our mission is not to inspire the
farmers that are currently fighting the
good fight it's to inspire their
children to do the right thing and do it
differently connected to new children
who are in the cities who are in the you
know tech world whoever wherever they
are connect those kids back give them a
sense of that unity give them a sense of
the oneness and give us all a sense that
this is the inescapable optimism as we
are going to transform period and it may
be I doubt up to the point of our death
or miraculously it might just happen
right before it that was one of the best
monologues I've ever heard of my life
pre ship brother that was amazing oh my
god
you're this incredible contradiction in
terms with the doomsday and the optimism
and the deep-rooted experience and
knowledge in science and yet somebody
with a vast capacity for for spiritual
exploration you're a wizard you're
against all our we all are and that's
the excitement that I have is you you
can't actually come close to the science
of atomic physics or astrophysics or
human biology without an overwhelming
sense of we are just so far beyond logic
we're so far beyond the material world
we are these entities that are moving
with such power and we have been kept
from that power and we've been kept from
it so that power can be taken from us
and consolidate in the hands of a few
right so the trick is can we come to
that realization that that that dawning
moment of consciousness expanding short
of the death experience
can we find the wherewithal the facility
to tap into that sense of what it means
to be alive while we are in the present
moment
three words humility first then
gratitude and love and if we can just
practice that at the scientific level at
the technological level at everything
other levels thank thank you for what
we've been given thank you for the the
horrendous drone journey we've had thank
you for the atrocities that we've had to
sustain as a people and thank you for a
mother nature that would continue to be
graceful to us why does she let her
Souls recover in 18 months why why
haven't you just wiped us off the face
of the planet yet why haven't you
smudged us out we are out there's ten to
the 31 viruses on earth ten to the 31
that's one with 31 zeros after it why
didn't they just knock us out the flu
virus is nothing there's ten to the 31
other viruses on the planet there's more
biologic life around us we are we are
one billionth of the life on the planet
why hasn't it all just crumped us out
pushed us out crushed us there's a
there's a crazy-ass paper that I wish I
had already won the Nobel Prize but it's
called the universal scaling laws by
astrophysicists and nassim haramein and
the x-axis the vertical axis on the
graph looks at the frequency of
resonance of every structure starting at
the universe itself whether its
resonance frequency all the way to
Planck's constant which is the vibration
of the electromagnetic field in vacuum
space tiniest little thing we can
measure and on the y axis the horizontal
axis you've got the the diameter or the
radius maybe it is of every one of those
structures and it turns out if you plot
the radius versus frequency of resonance
you get a straight line from Planck's
countenance constant all the way to the
universe dead center between the
smallest thing we've ever known and the
largest thing the universe itself is
human biology we're the mathematical
center point of the universe the average
size of the human being is that what
you're saying our frequency of resonance
plotted against our
what is how do you measure frequency of
resonance what is that it's we all
emanate electromagnetic frequency so
anything does rock does tree does any
any solid form will resonate an
electromagnetic field off of it and each
of those like like lightning frequency
red light having a different frequency
than blue light and so that does that's
the visible spectrum but then you've got
spectrum of frequency going all the way
out every direction to the almost
infinity points on those two directions
and so if we're the mathematical center
point it has something to do with the
fact that everything wants us here the
universe wants us here it's that
beautiful thing of when went the more
you know about science the more room
there is for wonder and awe yeah right
that is amazing so from the the smallest
measurable subatomic particle all the
way to what we estimate to be the size
of the universe where exactly in the
metal plot that against the frequency
and we are dead center yeah it should be
mind-blowing
it should recorrect our understanding of
what our purpose is our purpose is not
to be against nature we are of nature
and we're at its center point with great
purpose and it has to be that we would
have the consciousness that we would be
able to participate on the level of
consciousness to understand the concepts
of gratitude and love beautiful I can't
think of a better way to end this it's
fantastic that I could talk to you for
like eight hours so please I mean just
Agenda free come back and we'll just
like let it go wherever it wants to go
that was that was really beautiful thank
you for that things really are you are a
gift to humanity and please keep doing
what you're doing it's super important
work let me know or let the listeners
know how people can find you connect
with you
you know where can they learn more about
this docu-series and the nonprofit and
all the good things that you're doing a
long list of websites they're WWF
farmers footprint us is the docu-series
and the nonprofit and entry point for
you
WWE sack bush za c HB you sh m d comm
you can find a lot of my educational
material there in all these different
areas of health energy ecology are my
three main foci but i also have a huge
interest in changing the way business is
done and politics and the rest and so
Zach Busch is kind of your biggest
Clearinghouse of bizarre ideas the
agricultural stuff and the soil science
you can find more at restore the number
four life.com to many other websites
really named but that'll get that is you
know great yeah and i'll link up in the
show now it's a variety of other
resources so you can go down the rabbit
hole on Zach's world thanks so much for
hanging in my friend yeah I until next
time my friend all right peace place
regenerative soil
[Music]
you